it's funny that question began with the
mildly accusatory you're talking as if
you're the starter did you notice i i
have to go back and do a frame by frame
i don't know whether there was a little
middle finger swipe down the left ear
there like we saw i don't know if that's
what it was
but i don't think you know where he he
wasn't real thrilled with being
challenged on this point miles and yeah
hey this wouldn't be the first veteran
free agent who is told he's the starter
the day that he signs in march and then
is watching the draft in late april and
when the team for which he's the
starting quarterback is on the clock
drafts a quarter there it is there it is
well done i think he's scratching his
face with his middle finger hey you who
asked him that question take that um but
yeah hey there's a chance they're going
to take a quarterback at number 20
depending upon how the picks fall and
then he's still the starter until he
isn't
yeah i mean look that question i hadn't
heard that before we just listened to
that sound and that made me laugh man
like you're talking as if you're the
starter
a teenager and it's like do you actually
know what it is that you're saying
because i don't know that you do um and
yeah if i were him i would almost take a
little bit of offense to that because
it's not like andy dalton has been this
horrible horrible quarterback for all
his career i mean there's there's a band
that you may or may not have heard of
mike it's called bad bad not good and so
it's like i split that up basically into
two andy dalton is not bad bad but he's
also not good so i guess
you know when you think about what andy
dalton is right now and what he can be
it's not like anybody's expectations are
going to be sky high and they shouldn't
be but i think that he could be okay and
he can be middling but it's not like
he's taken a team to the playoffs for i
think seven years now i think the last
time the bengals made the playoffs was
2014. so i don't know it's just
i think that he deserved the question
you're talking as if you're the start or
what insurances do you have there
because
if he if that question wasn't asked how
would we know that he would he's had
those assurances
by the way bad bad not good is a
canadian instrumental music group and
production team from toronto ontario
founded in 2010 by bassist chester
hanson keyboardist matthew tavares and
drummer alexander zielinski who could
forget the great alexander sawinski how
dare you question my knowledge of bands
i just heard of for the first time 90
seconds ago
we had the graphic up andy dalton is
better than the bears andy dalton has as
many wins
as he's got more wins he's got 74 to the
bears 73 and he's got 66 losses and the
bears have 89. i'd say andy dalton's
done pretty well for himself since 2011
in comparison to the chicago bears
he is the chicago bears basically i mean
granted that you know he i guess he has
fewer losses a lot fewer losses but if
you got 23 fewer
but if you look at the raw numbers man i
mean like the touchdowns they're not too
far off he has fewer picks i get the
stacks of games pretty much the same
completion percentage i mean
the amount of wins though that's the
striking thing to me that they're just
about the same i don't know i think he
probably he probably fits in better than
we all have anticipated over the last
day or two
well and and and again that's why the
bar is low the guy went to five straight
playoffs to start his career
and after that 2016 17 18 19 in
cincinnati a lot of things went wrong he
didn't all of a sudden become a horrible
quarterback and they kept him until it
all bottomed out in 2019 and they earned
the number one overall pick and then
they go gonna go with joe burrow and
unlike when they had carson palmer and
kept john kitner around they decided
instead of sitting joe burrow we're
gonna throw him into the fray so we
don't need andy dalton so that was that
so i i i
there's there's just this strange
malaise and disrespect as it relates to
andy dalton and and that plays into the
bears hands i believe
for
2021 and back to that question like who
the hell's the starter if it's not andy
dalton they're paying the guy 10 million
dollars maybe that's why dalton gave him
the finger like how dumb are you it's
nick foles or me and they're giving me
10 million dollars
that tells people that this guy is is
pegged currently atop the depth chart
he's the starter and you know the money
is what tells you
the answer to your question not anything
that he was told privately by ryan pace
matt and aggie ted phillips or anyone
else
i think it's almost more have you been
told that you're going to be in a
competition or are they just giving you
the job outright and i think probably
more people would have at least expected
that
there would have been at least a show of
uh this is a competition rather than you
know here andy dalton here's this
quarterback uh
we've i don't know mike we don't know
i finally admit that nick foles is a bad
starter the only way it works for nick
foles and i still think that it was in
2017 it was like this strange football
slumdog millionaire thing where he just
managed to thread every needle that he
could
one after another until he's holding the
super bowl trophy but when he's a
starter
sims and i talked about this yesterday
the jaguars gave him four years 88
million dollars it was a disaster he
became the starter last year it was a
disaster um until he you know you heard
his butt on monday night against
oh
with rams
i watched all of those games they were
not very good you know the only good
thing about that was todd gurley and so
that's what saved him back then so no i
mean i agree with you that he's not a
good starter for whatever reason he is
doug peterson's news you know it just
works out when those two guys are
together and i think you know we saw
that even in 2018 when the eagles had a
chance to go down the field and beat the
saints down there in the superdome and
maybe if al-shawn jeffrey catches that
ball then carson once would have been
gone from you know philadelphia even
longer or shorter
but much before he was so i i don't know
i i think i don't think nick foles is
very good either and i think that he's
shown time and time again that he's not
a viable starter but
i don't know when it's andy dalton or
nick foles it's kind of like half a
dozen half a dozen to one and six of the
other right i don't know
when when i
uh think back to 2015
and the rams and nick foles the one
thing that impressed me more than
anything else was his uncanny ability to
make the football land on a spot of the
field where no one else was around
that that's a skill with that many guys
out there to actually put the ball and
have it land in a spot where no one else
is around i there should be some some
reward for that there should be
something it should be like a rouge you
should get a point like in canadian
football
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports